successful people aren't like everybody
else successful people act differently
think differently behave differently if
you want to predict somebody's future
success an accurate measure isn't gonna
be how much money they have it isn't
going to be what school they went to it
isn't gonna be what access to resources
they have a much more accurate measure
is gonna be what that person's mindset
is what that person's behaviors are what
that person's habits are so today I'm
gonna share with you the seven things
that you need to start doing differently
if you want to achieve success number
one being mediocre should be insulting
most people are mediocre most companies
are mediocre they're boring they're
average people are living for the
weekends the evenings they're not
inspired in their work on a day to day
basis you can't wait to go home and and
turn on the TV and and sit on the couch
for the evening because you're so
stressed out from your day-to-day life
that's being mediocre that's the most
people's lives that life that not doing
something you're passionate about that
not waking up every day and being
fulfilled in the work that you're doing
that should be insulting it should be
nauseating it should be important to you
what happens for a lot of people is you
can you live a life that that is
mediocre and you have these moments
these moments that you want to reach out
you know these moments where you believe
in yourself through a little bit more
bold than you normally are and then
smack you know the little man the little
man here pounds you back into where you
were back into your mediocre lifestyle
it has to be important to you you have
to feel it here has to make you insulted
nauseated this current life that you're
living until it becomes that important
until breaking free of your current
lifestyle becomes that important then
you're not going to make a change that's
why so many people they don't make that
change until they hit rock bottom
they've exhausted all opportunities that
hit rock bottom and they just don't care
anymore
they have to find a way they don't care
what people think anymore they don't
care about pressures that people are
putting on them and
more they have to find a way and that's
when they served the skyrocket being
mediocre should be insulting to you
number two is have a mindset for
greatness this is great Nike ad that I
love where it shows this fat kid running
this has find your greatness across his
chest and normally think of Nike is
having these ads with LeBron James or
Michael Jordan you know these athletes
the peak of their career and physical
specimens athletes you aspire to be
those are the people who are great and
here's this fat kid running and he's
supposed to be great and it's a change
for Nikes advertising and I love it and
I think whoever made that ad deserves a
raise because this speaks to having a
mindset for greatness because Michael
Jordan LeBron James Tiger Woods whatever
athlete you're throwing up there they
may have already accomplished all these
great things but to achieve that you
have to start earlier you need to have
the mindset for greatness and it starts
even though you might be this fat kid
right see that fat kid running wants to
be a marathon runner he wants to win an
Olympic gold medal in the in a marathon
and people look at him and say huh have
you seen yourself in a mirror do you
know what you look like you think you're
ever gonna win a gold medal and this is
what a lot of people do right we said
these are outrageous goals for ourselves
you have these big goals which are great
helps motivate inspire us and then the
outside the world pounces on us and
tells us all the reasons why we're not
gonna be able to accomplish it you need
to hold on to that mindset for greatness
because at the start you're going to
sock right you have this big goal you
want to win that gold medal if you're
just getting started as a runner you're
gonna suck maybe you only get across the
block and you're painting and you're
wheezing and and you like I can't I
can't do this anymore right I got a
break that's what most people quit right
you have this big goal you try it you
fail at it you suck at it and you quit
and you go back to your mediocre life
that's what you need to keep going
because when you first learn anything
any new thing that you try to learn you
are going to suck at it at the start you
try to ride a bicycle you try to learn
French you try to learn how to cook
whatever it is whatever new skill you're
trying to learn you will suck you look
back at my videos you may like them now
you go back to the first ones I saw
they were terrible but through practice
and repetition I got better and I can do
them way faster so will you if you
continue to hone your craft you continue
to beat on it every single day and get
better you will get better you will get
more results and the difference is
inside your thinking that you're great
but the results you're creating aren't
great yet and it's being able to manage
that difference manage that gap and soon
that gap will start to close soon what
you feel in your mind of what you're
capable of will actually mirror what
you're creating and maybe even surpass
but that early step is so important you
need to have the mindset for greatness
you need to have that mindset where you
feel like you can accomplish something
big and not just once not just in that
little five-minute window where you're
feeling bold but consistently every
single day successful people have a
mindset for greatness
number three is discover your one word I
believe that everybody has one word that
defines them that sums them up and when
you discover that it makes every
decision that you want to make in your
personal and your business life so much
easier and the greatest people in the
world the people who've accomplished the
greatest things can often easily be
summed up into one word right Martin
Luther King stood for quality Steve Jobs
was impact Oprah Winfrey was heart you
gotta find what your one word is so
start to add clarity meaning and purpose
to your life so mine is about belief
right my one word is believe it is from
every video that I I create for you guys
and it makes every decision in my life
so much easier
so if I'm hiring somebody for example
right hiring is a huge problem for a lot
of entrepreneurs say I'm hiring a new
computer programmer for my website I
don't just look at the skills right you
can have this great person looks great
on paper has all the skills that you
need but if that person isn't about
belief if that person have the belief
mindset he or she's not gonna work out
for me it's not gonna be a good fit it
makes every single decision easier from
hiring to marketing to creating content
to raising capital to getting press to
giving people a message to spread for
you stand for something important
through your one word you have to have
that one big word number four have a big
why most people when they start a
business they have a small goal you know
I want to make X amount of dollars to
pay my bills
if money is your goal you're never gonna
make a lot of money if you look at the
most successful entrepreneurs of all
time look at their stories look across
generations look at why they started it
they had a big why they wanted to have a
big impact somehow they wanted to change
the way something was done they were so
unhappy so dissatisfied with the way
things are currently being done in their
industry that they had to change it and
such as entrepreneurs the people who've
led social movements anything anything
great look at the great people somebody
comes to mind as a as a great leader
look at why they started it wasn't to
make a lot of money money is a byproduct
of doing something meaningful if you're
helping people and they're really
meaningful way if you're creating change
and you're adding value to people's
lives you will make money but if money
is your only goal you're never gonna
make it you have to have something that
you are deeply passionate about you have
to have something when you look on the
wall - oh I want to go accomplish that
this means something to me so you need
to have a big why and that should be
your guiding purpose what is that big
why for you number five to take
immediate action successful people take
immediate action to start building
momentum here's what the non successful
people do here's what most people will
do you have this big goal you have this
dream and for for five minutes for an
hour for an afternoon you're inspired
right you're you're inspired to take
action for that little moment of time
you're ready to bust out of your
mediocrity yes I believe in myself I'm
gonna go do this big thing and maybe
write down a plan and then you sleep on
it and the next day you wake up and you
look at what you wrote down it's like I
can't I'm not gonna do that that that
sounds way too big that a body I must
have been on something when I was
thinking of that how am I gonna be able
to accomplish that you start to doubt
yourself right the your your routine
your life the people around you yourself
your inner voice smacks you back down
the little man
smacks you back down to where you work
to be really successful all you really
need to do is be able to in that moment
you need to have the five minutes
boldness to take action you have a goal
you get excited about something you take
immediate action even if it's small take
immediate action if you're watching this
video and you're saying you know I'm
gonna start making videos this is
something I'm gonna I want to start
doing I think it's important I think I
could be good at it don't just write it
down I'll leave the until tomorrow leave
it till next week cause it's never gonna
get done right now make your video you
have a goal you want to step outside
your comfort zone you want to bust
through that barrier that's holding you
back in your life right now take
immediate action as soon as you get
inspired as soon as you get motivated
you got to take action right away that's
what successful people do because it
builds momentum it starts building and
then the next thing when you wake up all
that momentum is carried forward and if
you've committed to somebody else and
said hey I've got this great idea I want
to start I want to I want to meet with
you for coffee to talk about it now
you've committed to that person you have
to go through with it where if you just
leave it as an idea as a wish list and
you write it down so here are things I'm
gonna do that list just gets bigger and
bigger and bigger and you don't take any
action on it and you're never going to
get to where you want to be so take
immediate action as soon as you start
realizing a goal of yours that you want
to move forward on number six create a
supportive environment the environment
that you've created for yourself is by
design should be by design and right now
it's holding you in place the people you
surround yourself with the music you
listen to your daily routine a lot of it
you just you're on autopilot this is
what you do every morning and it hasn't
been designed to build you up to support
you you need to create a routine create
an environment that builds you up start
the day with music start the day with
something that will get you bumping so
let's start moving around surround
yourself with people who believe when
your ideas who make you want to become a
better person walk into an office
whether it's a basement office or a big
corporate tower wherever you are walk
into it and design it to it so it's a
point of that that it excites you right
put things up on the wall have things
that that remind you of why you're doing
this thing who you're doing it for the
change you want to make in the world
your your environment needs to build you
up where for most of us the media we
consume the books you read the
newspapers we look at the magazines the
people we hang around with the TV shows
we watch just hold us here hold us at
yogurt holders that boring hold us at
average so start to think now okay this
life we want to create for yourself what
does my environment have to be around me
from the people I'm hanging out with
from the videos that I'm watching from
the music I'm listening to from the
things that hang on my wall what needs
to change write down five things they
need to change in your current
environment right now back to the last
point take immediate action write down
the five things right now pause the
video write down those five things and
then go to actually do them don't say
yeah I want to put things up on my wall
that are gonna inspire me you write that
down and I listen you never actually do
it do it today right now take action
create a lifestyle and create an
environment that supports you a number
seven is build a team you cannot do this
by yourself whatever big goal you have
whatever big dream you want accomplish
you can't do it alone you need help you
need people to help you you need support
and it doesn't have to be full-time it
doesn't even have to be paid you can
find the volunteers interns the first
guy I hired was for one hour a day just
to ease some of the burden off of me
he's the crap that didn't want to deal
with that he loved so I could focus on
the bigger picture CEO time stuff the
more time you're spending doing the non
important work right like 80% plus of
the work you're doing you shouldn't be
doing doesn't mean that it shouldn't be
done some of it shouldn't be done but
most of it you shouldn't be doing so
start it doesn't mean you have to hire
somebody full-time but start building a
team and realizing that you cannot do
this yourself because successful people
they build teams they create an
environment people are attracted to them
because of all the things we talked
about because they have a big why
because they have a mindset for
greatness because they're standing for
something important because they're
trying to make a meaningful impact on
the world because they clearly
articulate their one word right that
attracts people like-minded people to
want to work with you to help you on
your mission so number seven is
realizing that you can't do this on your
own and start building a team even if
it's a volunteer even if it's for one
hour Tay
start building your team so in summary
the seven things you need to do
differently if you want success number
one being mediocre should be insulting
number two have a mindset for greatness
number three discovery or one word
number four have a big why number five
take immediate action
number six create a supportive
environment number seven
build the team and believe you guys
liked this video you want to see more
you can subscribe to the channel thank
you so much for watching I'll see you
soon if you want some believe in your
inbox every week to keep you motivated
check out the link below to join my
newsletter